♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT"."
EVERY CULT HAS THE SAME GOAL:
THE UTTER SUBMISSION OF ITS
MEMBERS.
CULT MEMBERS SURRENDER
EVERYTHING.
THEY GIVE UP THEIR PHYSICAL
FREEDOM, WHERE THEY CAN GO, WHO
THEY CAN SEE, HOW THEY CAN
DRESS, BUT MORE THAN THAT, THEY
GIVE UP CONTROL OF THEIR MINDS.
CULT LEADERS DETERMINE WHETHER
FOLLOWERS ARE ALLOWED TO
BELIEVE, EVEN IN THEIR MOST
PRIVATE THOUGHTS.
IN ORDER TO DO THIS, CULT
SEPARATE PEOPLE FROM ALL THEY
HAVE KNOWN BEFORE AND FORCED
THEIR MEMBERS TO RENOUNCE THEIR
FORMER LIVES, THEIR COUNTRIES,
THEIR CUSTOMS.
THEY WILL HAVE NO LOYALTY EXCEPT
TO THE CULT.
THE FIRST THING THEY ATTACK
ALWAYS IS THE FAMILY.
FAMILIES ARE THE MAIN IMPEDIMENT
TO BRAINWASHING AND EXTREMISM,
THAT IS TRUE IN EVERY CULTURE.
SO IF YOU’RE GOING TO CONTROL
INDIVIDUALS, YOU’RE GOING TO
TRANSFORM FREE PEOPLE INTO
COMPLIANT ROBOTS, THE FIRST
THING YOU MUST DO IS SEPARATE
THEM FROM THE ONES WHO LOVE THE
MOST.
IN 1932, SOVIET AUTHORITIES
BEGAN PROMOTING THE STORY OF A
13-YEAR-OLD PEASANT BOY.
THEY CLAIMED HE HAD TAKEN THESE
EXTREMELY VIRTUOUS STEP OF
DENOUNCING HIS OWN FATHER TO THE
SECRET POLICE FOR COMMITTING
COUNTERREVOLUTIONARY ACTS.
ONCE EXPOSED AS A TRAITOR, THE
BOY’S FATHER WAS EXECUTED BY
FIRING SQUAD FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE STATE.
JOSEPH STALIN ELEVATED THIS BOY
TO THE STATUS OF NATIONAL HERO
FOR WHAT HE DID.
PEOPLE WEPT IN THE STREETS WHEN
THEY HEARD HIS NAME, THEY
WORSHIPED HIM LIKE A SAINT.
WHY ARE WE TELLING YOU THIS?
BECAUSE IT’S HAPPENING HERE.
IN THE LAST TEN DAYS, SOME OF
OUR MOST PROMINENT CITIZENS HAVE
SWORN ALLEGIANCE TO OCCULT.
CONVERTS GO BY THE TERM
"ALLIES," AND LIKE ALL CULT
MEMBERS, THEY DEMAND TOTAL
CONFORMITY.
THEY RITUALLY CONDEMN THEIR OWN
NATION.
ITS HISTORY, ITS NATIONS, IT’S
SYMBOLS, ITS FLAG.
THEY DENOUNCE THEIR OWN PARENTS.
IF YOU’VE BEEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA
RECENTLY YOU’VE LIKELY SEEN MANY
VIDEOS LIKE THIS ONE.
>> STUPID [BLEEP] DINOSAUR!
GET THE [BLEEP] OUT OF HERE!
I’M SORRY, YOU GUYS.
>> Tucker: THAT AS A CHILD
ATTACKING HER MOTHER AND FATHER
FOR THE CRIME OF INSUFFICIENT
LOYALTY TO BLACK LIVES MATTER.
SHE WROTE ABOUT THIS VIDEO AND
STRONGLY APPROVED OF IT.
WHAT YOU JUST SAW IT AS A YOUNG
PERSON "MODELING THE MOST
IMPORTANT TENET OF ALLY SHIP."
MODELING, MEANING SOMETHING DONE
TO ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO DO THE
SAME.
IT’S EFFECTIVE AND IN THIS CASE,
IT’S WORKING.
HERE’S A 15-YEAR-OLD FROM
LOUISIANA CALLED ISABELLA.
THERE ARE MANY LIKE HER IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
>> I LITERALLY HATE MY FAMILY SO
MUCH.
THEY JUST HAD TO ARGUE WITH ME
THAT GEORGE FLOYD, THEY JUST
TRIED TO TELL ME THAT HE
DESERVED THAT BECAUSE HE DID
SOMETHING WRONG AND THAT IT WAS
OKAY.
THAT IS NOT OKAY.
[SNIFFLING]
AND IT’S MAKING ME SO UPSET.
I DO NOT WANT TO LIVE HERE.
I HATE LIVING IN LOUISIANA.
I HATE LIVING IN ALL THESE
RACIST --
>> Tucker: I HATE MY FAMILY SO
MUCH.
JUST A WEEK AGO IT WOULD’VE BEEN
HARD TO IMAGINE THAT.
NOW ISABELLA IS A SOCIAL MEDIA
STAR.
CELEBRITIES TWEET THEIR APPROVAL
AT HER.
SHE MAY HAVE HER OWN CULT
FOLLOWING BEFORE LONG BUT THE
REVOLUTION IS YOUNG.
CHILDREN ATTACKING THE PARENT IS
JUST THE BEGINNING APPEARED ON
CNN TODAY, MAN TOLD VIEWERS THAT
GOING FORWARD, PARENTS MUST
HURT THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
>> I THINK THAT THE IMPORTANT
THING FOR WHITE PARENTS TO KEEP
IN THE FRONT OF OUR MINDS IS
THAT IF BLACK CHILDREN IN THIS
COUNTRY ARE NOT ALLOWED
INNOCENCE AND CHILDHOOD WITHOUT
FEAR OF BEING KILLED BY POLICE
OR MARGINALIZED IN SOME OTHER
WAY, THEN OUR CHILDREN DON’T
DESERVE INNOCENCE.
IF JIMMY RICE CAN BE SHOT DEAD I
PARK PLAYING WITH A TOY GUN,
SOMETHING WHITE CHILDREN DO
EVERY DAY WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
BEING SHOT, IF HE CAN BE KILLED
THAN WHITE CHILDREN NEED TO
BE TOLD AT LEAST AT THE SAME
AGE.
IF THEY CAN’T BE INNOCENT, WE
DON’T GET TO BE INNOCENT.
>> Tucker: YOUR CHILDREN ARE
NO LONGER ALLOWED TO BE
INNOCENT, SAYS TIM WISE.
HAPPY CHILDHOOD IS A SIGN OF
RACISM.
THE MAN SAYING THIS IS A
SELF-DESCRIBED ANTIRACISM
ACTIVIST.
HE’S BEEN SAYING THINGS LIKE
THIS FOR A LONG TIME.
MORE THAN ONCE TIM WISE HAS
SUGGESTED HE APPROVES OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST THOSE WHO
DISAGREE.
HOW DOES TIM WISE MAKE A LIVING?
IN PART BY LECTURING STUDENTS.
YOUR KIDS MAY HAVE SEEN HIM
SPEAK.
YOU’VE CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT OF
PEOPLE LIKE TIM WISE.
IN AMERICA’S SCHOOLS, THE
REVOLUTION HAS BEEN IN PROGRESS
FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
ROCHESTER IN NEW YORK HAS BEEN A
BLACK LIVES MATTER THEMED LESSON
PLAN, INCLUDING DISMISSING
AMERICA’S BEDROCK INSTITUTIONS
IN AMERICA ITSELF IS INHERENTLY
RACIST.
QUESTIONS INCLUDE, HOW DOES MASS
INCARCERATION AND FUNCTION AS A
MECHANISM OF RACIALIZED SOCIAL
CONTROL?
ONE SPECIFIC RACIAL GROUP IS
SINGLED OUT FOR EXCLUSIVE BLAME.
THE CURRICULUM PROMOTES A BOOK
CALLED "WHITE RAGE: THE UNSPOKEN
RACIAL TRUTH OF OUR DIVIDE."
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE’S A REASON
HATRED AND INEQUALITY EXISTS.
THESE PEOPLE DID IT!
THAT’S WHAT YOUR KIDS ARE
LEARNING RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT.
YESTERDAY IN IOWA, THE PRINCIPAL
SENT AN EMAIL TO THE PARENTS IN
WHICH HE PROMISED TO INCREASE
THE "RACE CONSCIOUS EDUCATION OF
OUR STUDENTS."
HE DISTRIBUTED MATERIALS FROM
THE SOUTHERN POVERTY LAW CENTER.
IRONICALLY, THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER IS ITSELF A HATE
GROUP.
THAT IS BEEN DOCUMENTED
EXTENSIVELY, BUT NOW THEIR
AGENDA IS THE SCHOOL’S AGENDA.
IT’S WHAT YOUR KIDS ARE
LEARNING.
IN THE AFFLUENT NORTHWEST
SECTION OF THE CITY, PRINCIPAL
RECENTLY WROTE A LETTER SAYING
"WE NEED MORE WHITE PARENTS TO
TALK TO THEIR KIDS ABOUT RACE,
ESPECIALLY NOW."
THE LETTER SINGLED OUT "WHITE
STAFF AND WHITE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS" WHO THE PRINCIPAL
ALLEGED COMMITTED MACRO AND
MICRO AGGRESSIONS AGAINST STAFF
OF COLOR APPEAR THE PRINCIPAL
DID NOT SPECIFY WHAT THOSE
CRIMES WERE.
SHE DIDN’T NEED TO.
THEIR SKIN COLOR WAS THEIR
CRIME.
THIS IS A NATIONAL THEME.
IT PAINS US TO TELL YOU THAT BUT
IT’S TRUE.
IT’S INCREDIBLY DESTRUCTIVE AND
DANGEROUS.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE NOW USING
THE 1619 PRODUCT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FOR EXAMPLE
AS A CURRICULUM.
THAT PROJECT IS THE RESULT OF AN
OUT OF THE CLOSET RACIAL
EXTREMIST, WHO RECENTLY ARGUED
IT IS NOT VIOLENCE TO LOOT AND
BURN STORES, IT’S JUSTIFIED.
HER CURRICULUM IS NOT MANDATORY
IN SCHOOLS IN BUFFALO, CHICAGO,
NEWARK, WASHINGTON.
MANY PARENTS UNDERSTANDABLY
DEEPLY RESENT THIS.
IT’S A DERANGED IT’S RACIST, BUT
OTHER PARENTS DON’T.
THEY ARE ALLIES AND THEY’VE
JOINED IN.
ONE MOTHER IN LONDON WHERE THE
CULT IS ALSO SPREADING POSTED
THIS PHOTO ON TWITTER.
IT’S OF HER DAUGHTER ON BENDED
KNEE HOLDING A SIGN DECLARING
HER PRIVILEGE.
THE CULTURAL REVOLUTION HAS COME
TO THE WEST.
WHAT WILL THE EFFECTS OF THIS
BE?
THIS IS JUST A MOMENT.
IT WILL END.
HOW WILL WE FEEL ABOUT LOOKING
BACK?
YEARS FROM NOW, HOW WILL THAT
LITTLE GIRL WITH THE SIGN
REMEMBER HER CHILDHOOD?
HER MOTHER TOOK TIM WISE’S
ADVICE.
SHE NO LONGER HAS INNOCENCE.
WILL SHE BE GRATEFUL FOR THAT?
IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE SHE WILL
BE.
MORE LIKELY SHE WILL FEEL THAT
HER AND USED BECAUSE SHE HAS
BEEN USED.
AND IT’S LIKELY THAT MANY
CHILDREN GROWING UP RIGHT NOW
WILL FEEL THE SAME WAY.
IS THERE A SINGLE PERSON WHO
BELIEVES THAT THIS MOMENT WE ARE
LIVING THROUGH WILL END IN
RACIAL HARMONY?
THAT USED TO BE WHAT WE WANTED.
SOME OF US STILL DO WANT THAT.
IS IT EVEN A GOAL ANYMORE?
IT DOESN’T SEEM LIKE IT.
INSTEAD, IT SEEMS LIKE MANY IN
POWER -- IT’S VERY CLEAR, IN
FACT -- ARE PUSHING HARD FOR
RACIAL DIVISION.
FOR HATRED, FOR VIOLENCE.
AND LET’S PRAY THEY DON’T GET
WHAT THEY WANT.
TRIBAL CONFLICT WILL DESTROY A
COUNTRY FASTER THAN ANY PLAGUE.
BUT KEEP IN MIND, AS THIS
INSANITY CONTINUES, THAT IT
DOESN’T HAPPEN IN A VACUUM.
EVERY ACTION PROVOKES A
REACTION.
THAT’S A PHYSICS.
WE DON’T KNOW WHERE THIS IS
GOING, WE DON’T WANT TO KNOW
WHERE IT’S GOING.